what does home mean to you it's a big
project with a bold ambition Prince
William wants to end homelessness
which is why I'm launching homewards
[Music]
a program that commits to working with
six locations across the UK over the
next five years
it's his first intervention as Prince of
Wales
Wales long supported and won very close
to his heart as boys his mother took him
and Harry to the charity the passage
[Music]
and on his 21st birthday to Newport with
his father opening a homeless Center
these early visits made an impact and
left the Legacy he's continued the
prince in Peckham recently as patron of
Centerpoint visiting the Charities new
Flats but his homewood's project goes
even further bringing together local
groups and people to find local
solutions to homelessness wherever my
dog is Sabrina Hatton Cohen is closely
involved she's one of the UK's most
senior fire officers but as a teenager
was sleeping rough I've been really
impressed by the prince's personal
investment in this and in particular the
way that he's acknowledged The Human
Side of homelessness and the way that he
wants to take a really kind of
person-centric approach so it's not just
about giving somebody a house this is
about the rest of the challenges that
come with surviving homelessness some
might say ending homelessness is for
politicians not princes and this project
certainly puts the Prince of Wales in a
political Arena but this is an issue he
wants changing as heir to the throne his
father wasn't afraid to speak out and
neither it seems is William Laura
bundock Sky News